You gotta be on in those moments?
Yes.
That's all.
That's what I'm saying.
Help me too.
Do you,
do you miss being not sober that summertime sometimes.
Yeah.
I um,
I miss well they pros and cons that,
that if I do,
I'll end up doing too much for sure.
For sure.
I can't control it.
It's just the way you are.
Just the way I am and I don't want to,
I don't want to push it again because when I get that way,
my kids don't talk to me.
I get a divorce,
I'm thrown out of my own band.
Uh,
what else?
I lose everything.
I mean,
it's happened enough times for me to finally realize,
you know what,
it's not worth it.
Right.
You know,
I get it.
You see what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And I got a lot of beautiful friends.
I've got a beautiful,
um,
bunch of friends to keep me in line.
You know,
I got two sponsors,
one on the west coast,
one on the east coast.
I had to call up all the time ago.
I want to get so fucked up.
Right.
How does that work?
When you call them out,
what do they do it Steven?
No,
no.
Fuck Dude,
I do too.
And I keep it together.
Exactly.
And I was,
they'll just say what else is new?
Did you guys ever talk about it that way?
Like fat people talk about food they used to eat.
No,
cause we don't do that.
What was it called?
Looking back and take it into the dinosaur shit.
No one would do that.
But you do.
If you go to like an AA meeting,
they do get up and tell awesome stories.
Oh fuck.
You're getting fucked up.
Right.
See when you get sober,
if you don't,
if you don't continue your aftercare by going to a couple of meetings every now
and then you're going to wind up using again.
Really?
Especially someone like me who watched Janis Joplin up there.
Okay,
1968 I'm in a high school.
She's got bangles and beads like this shit on and she's,
she's drinking southern comfort and she's spitting and using the f word,
smoking cigarettes.
Nobody did that back then.
She was a powerful watching her and she's fucking the power in song.
That's why I covered that.
How my country album.
Yeah.
To this day,
I listen to that song like at least once every couple of months.
Put that in the headphones.
You see how serious what songs can do for you.
Well,
when you,
when you grew up in the 60s and what we did was we experimented,
you know,
I mean,
if you think about what they tell us,
Christopher Columbus discovered America know the bow of his boat was full of
booze and he fucked Queen Elizabeth or whoever.
She goes,
go,
good boy.
You know,
and she sent him on his way with some money.
He said,
bring them back.
Some countries you think,
and by the way,
he wasn't the first person here.
That's what America wants us to believe.
Anyway,
so,
so Christopher Columbus,
he's got that in his head to go to go check shit out.
Right?
He's drinking,
he's going by the stars at night.
It's kind of like that.
It's like he never took LSD.
It's,
I've taken acid.
Okay,
so then you,
you know what you look out.
We used to take acid in high school and we would,
we'd go to these,
um,
uh,
ski slopes in the summertime,
right?
Beautiful Green hills going up.
And we'd ride the chairlifts stoned as fuck.
And we got our stuff from San Francisco,
from Ozzie.
I would call him up and go,
dude,
more colors,
rate to bounce,
going to kill me.
But that's what,
so you understand that that's just,
it's,
it's like,
you know,
is it fucked up in its drugs?
Yeah.
But you're also,
it's like,
I'd love to do Iowasca.
I'd love to hear maybe my bucket list,
and that's what I'll talk to my sponsor about.
Hey,
I got this,
uh,
I'm in Maui.
Maybe I've been here too long,
but I'm over.
And Hannah,
they're doing IOWASCA.